so
[Music]
um
so
[Music]
what's that about
um
[Music]
this is not going to end well just keep
your wits about you
call me
me and ava will take care of this i know
cigarette is there a problem we'll go
see tundra just the two of us eva and
ubba will wait here better if tomna
thinks we've come alone the truth is i
don't think any of us can stop eva from
cleaving her hat open it's all he was
spewing the whole way over here right
shall we we'll return shortly a small
fortune for whoever sent tona to hell
i'll hold you to that
from what i overheard in repton the
brothers had an arrangement with toner
what happened she's a mercenary uber
used her for man and information but
that relationship soured now that
burgret is all but defeated from what i
heard
tana has hunger for two things
soft silver
and a stern hump neither of which earns
you true loyalty if she can't be trusted
what use is she that is for us to find
out we may be able to satisfy her and if
we can't eva did tell you to bring your
axe
and here they are as expected if she
takes a liking to you
keep talking
what brings you strolling into my camp
this birthday i suspect you already know
yes
the emperors on the air betray you and
yet if you are here talking to me king
bergeron remains at large
and who are you lovely dove
want to perch your ass on my lap
not interested and why not
i've been told i have a rather expert
tongue
only good for your pain i see
enough blubbering
you know why we're here where is king
bergeret that is what you want
and what makes you think i have the
slightest idea
we found letters
records of trade
the two of you have a history what can i
say the king pays well for my services
if only i could say the same for those
two ragnarsson clutch you're dealing
with me now and i want to know what you
know
name your
price well
i could use another cow
and you can cover the cost
when sheolf is on the throne do you
think he'll be pleased to hear you stood
in his way that you doubted him at all
settle for half that amount and maybe
chairwolf's first command won't be for
your head on a platter
you've got stones
out with it
burger had paid me to steer the ragna
songs clear of two areas led chester and
temple brokfort
it was a hefty amount
if i were you that's where i'd look and
that is all i know not more not less we
are done here
ledesre and temple broth ford
do you know these places
i don't but the brothers will i'll bring
this news to them
don't stay around here too long
we've got a king to catch
watch yourself lovely dove
secrets told us the news well done
ledestre and temple brought fort
what do you know about them
hmm
leather chest is a large village
contemply brock
it's an old military fort not much else
berkeley could be at either one we
should check both as soon as possible
and what do we do with tona
i would bet the sweat off my sack she's
writing to poor grit now offering silver
for a warning about us
let me worry about that
we should get moving drink it i can take
the fortress at temple block i will join
you sigurd
that leaves me lead the chesterton all
by my [__] lonesome
bring your friend brother
maybe avor dares to be called that
go on ahead i'll catch up with all of
you soon
[Music]
share with us
okay
this must be the bathhouse we need to
find a way inside
hey
[Music]
me
this is bollocks we should be out there
fighting to take tamworth back from the
danes we're to secure our stores first
they offer its service they're frith's
orders
the king's grown tired of him you know
that's what all the men are saying tight
how do you mean are you blind
he questions bergeron's orders every
chance he gets us done ever since the
danes showed up
jailbed
have you lost your mind i feared you
were one of them keep quiet
what are you doing here i'm
i was looking for burghrad you are evil
scout i hoped i might find burger myself
and talk him into surrendering but he's
not in leather chester how can you be
sure leopard passed this way with some
men my eavesdropped
it seems they're only stockpiling food
here but he did say something of
interest
gave orders to send more men to berger's
wife the lady arville smith
she's in temple
she would know where berger is hiding
the sounds of battle evi
let's get you out of here now where are
you going i know my way around we'll go
through the market this way
we have this
they're everywhere
stay close to me
what do do
oh
i will burn it all down
are you hurt speak up
i don't think so
my god
i didn't want it to come to this it
would have killed you chill birth you
had no choice now don't move
where is your king saxon
where is he
lord our father grant me salvation
when does their god find the time to
answer so much mumbling and whimpering
you're reckless evil chao bed could have
been killed who am i to stand in the
light of a boy searching for his boss
don't excuse yourself you enjoy this too
much
stop
it wasn't eva who sent me
i sent myself have caution boy
until your father's crowned your
merciest enemy not its champion
you understand i understand
good
now return to repton and remain there
until we call will you not stay wolf
kissed there is no king but we have
corpses to loot bergrid's lady arthur
swift is in temple broth
i'm going to find out what she knows
take
so
[Music]
welcome after steve
did i ever tell you all the story of how
i killed an entire clan single-handedly
ugly was an excellent sailor who could
pilot a longship entirely on his own
this is why king sequality kept him
around in all other matters luna was a
cruel anxious and humorless man he was
one of the most unlikable people i have
ever known one year i recall we had
invited some pearls from the england
clan to guidebooks as we were serving
ale we came to find that we had none
left it so happened that yale had run
out just before reaching unarch
this raised in him a word storm and he
excused sig valley of treachery every
man in the long house cheered at luna
for raising such a fuss this made who
not angrier than before
please
every man in the long house cheered at
luna for racing such a bus
this made oonagh angrier than before but
he stormed out a short time later we
heard him yelling through the door of
the hall
one of the heads of the england's horses
and stuck it up on a hazel branch when
he saw us gathering
they saw us gathering at the door the
england carls among us wound our panic
and ran
he was not seen for many months
[__]
he'll never say anything again
we've told you everything what
aver there you are
what's with the prisoners man from the
fortress out on patrol
we squeeze them burger's not here
it's his queen they're guarding others
with
they must have separated after tomworth
i heard as much from cheryl bert and
letter chester jailbert
what was he doing there
eva
too long a tale for now but he's fine i
send him to repton
what's the plan here
it won't be long before someone comes
looking for these men
we need to get inside and find others
with
capture a queen to find a king it might
work
only one way to find out
see if you can get anything more out of
them
me and aber will take care of fetching
others with
oh then guide you
the saxons won't welcome us through the
front door
we could find a quiet way in
or we can take your longship
i'm beside you either way ah
i have dreamt of this day of scouring
the shy in search of a king of going a
vegan good with you
with our brothers and sisters
conquering new lands forming lasting
friendships and if it takes chasing some
weasel across a new land so be it i am
right where i wish to be as am i brother
uh
oh
[Music]
huh
soldiers barracks
others with might be here
we bring christ mercy
oh
[Music]
wow
so
[Music]
who
wants you
ugh
uh
you three
scurry
lady offers with i see burgreat has done
his best to hide you away
but what is lost must always be found
let my handmaidens walk free of this
place they have nothing to do with our
quarrel
you hear that ever
noble
selfless
this is the sword you must strike a
bargain with a woman of quality
we seek only your king lady
tell us where budgrad hides and we will
leave without an ounce of blood spilt
please i
i don't
i don't know
effective sigurd
she's only naive to her present danger
but she will soon understand
wait
those are the hands of one who washes
linens a servant
she is a decoy
oh god
come quickly
they found me
watch the handmaidens i'll follow
ethel's wish
[Music]
take the phone down
your date
father
[Applause]
healthy
[Music]
hey
stay away from me
my husband will send you all to hell
quite clever you ladies chip you're
certainly making us work for it keep
your hands off me pagan have you lost
your sense of hospitality
i regret asking stay away from me let me
go
i demand it after what you put me
through i would have to be mad do you
understand what you're doing pagan i am
the lady of mercier stay away from me
you're wasting your time i won't talk
not to you not to any of you barbarians
you may reconsider if only for your
people who knows how many more might die
at
you don't frighten me and you are a fool
my husband will send you all to hell
stop what you are doing at once
don't you dare put your hand
what
watch out fool
lady others with
you have seen better days
god will fear your soul heathen if he
can find it
quite the catchable
she is as much a poet as you
where's my kathleen
what have you done with her your
handmaiden you mean the brave one
dressed in royal finery season change
with the others i'll take them back to
tamworth get them talking if she has so
much as a scratch on her
i will inform cheerwolf he might have
some ideas on how to get through to her
i will meet you there
ziggurt
what about these prisoners we've got
what we need
let them go
hmm
so
your turn
she won't talk to me
ever will handle it go on
you've exhausted my friend abba here but
i'm wide awake maybe tell me where
burger is hiding and let him rest happy
never
stone-faced and tied lipped all for a
king who hides like a cowardly bowl too
scared to protect his family and his
people
thirsty
my husband does what he must for mercy
how could he do otherwise knowing that
even his closest friends could betray
him
give that traitor chao wolf my message
he may win this earthly battle but the
devil has won the war for his soul
i don't care how you feel about
cheowwolf but he will be king it's only
a matter of when
burgret is king
elected by the witten and anointed by
god my lady i know what the losing side
looks like and you're on it we've taken
repton tamworth now temple brock and let
it chester with each victory your hope
for peace recedes yet bulbred has what
you do not the loyalty of his people
good men
faithful men who the thanes and jails of
mercia no no only leophrase remains
loyal and he too will fall yes goodly
leofrith he will die defending his king
and win or lose he will send a hundred
more of you to hell
avor
your ladyship
do not mind me only here to count my
spoils
oh god
out either now all right all right but
if you mean to stay
mind the smell after they finish this
my god
get me out of here
please
talk now and we'll draw you a nice warm
bath
you
you are asking me to betray my husband
how can i do that
if you don't you will betray countless
others in legend you may be remembered
as the king and queen who abandoned
their kingdom in its darkest hour but
there will be peace
this is jaywal's promise and it will be
honored
you have my word
does the caged bird sing
bergrid is hiding in an old trip to the
south
where the arnie and aero rivers join a
crypt
now tell me this is not a sign from the
gods
it's a long way to carry a king
the three of you must clear a path back
to tamworth where can we meet bring him
to the bridge at venomnus
it's a straight line through
we'll deal with any trouble there
the heads were a nice touch i'm not one
for spectacle but it got her talking
spectacle
that's just me
take everything
[Music]
over here
so
uh
[Music]
a musty crypt
cannot be the dead they're protecting
oh
try to flank
your fate
with me here
coming for you
[Music]
oh
ugh
uh
maybe god for a musty crypt
cannot be the dead they're protected
hmm
uh
[Music]
oh
ugh
[Music]
uh
ah
darkness beckons raven kittens
[Music]
uh
um
[Music]
hmm
uh
ah
stop right there
steadfast
come on
get round the side
with me brother
right for christmas
he's got to be down here
where are you hiding bergrid
bloody [__]
so
go
i must be getting close
my lord intruders
uh
no
no no no it can't be stay back
that's a bread knife my lord do you mean
to bother me
stay back back i say i'll fight you
if you insist
you'll have to kill me luckily for you
it won't come to that this kingdom is
mine
you have to kill me
i won't let you defeat me
i will not yield
you have to kill me
[Music]
huh
time to go my lord we're late for the
crowning ceremony
ugh
so
[Music]
you're finished your time has come
oh
[Music]
you you think you've won
you haven't
liar
i i sent him away with orders to destroy
you quiet the mess you're in
you don't know the half of it
you're a blight on this world
the old lot of you
a rancid disease you don't deserve
mercier to the victor the spoils my lord
you must win mercier to the server
[Music]
we need to go fast right behind you
you old beauty i hardly recognized you
there
pile the soldiers here
ah
put me down only way you go down is with
a rope around your neck
they'll be coming for him stay alert
pile the soldiers here
let these people bear witness to the
carnage that awaits their kingdom
you're gonna die
[Music]
more of them to me my soldiers i'm here
they've got the king
here we are
look familiar no
no you
you godless slugs
you won't get away with this
[Music]
change has come bergrid
all that remains is a coronation
and we turn with the lords of mercier
foregrip my love
my lady
are you injured
did i hurt you
no no
i'm fine
move along lord your king awaits
your death will come times
your end was
the moment you came for me i have made
damn sure of that
the zealots will know your name soon
enough
no matter where you are or how far you
travel they will hunt you down
enough of that you squeaking sparrow
let my brother be the lunatic of
tamworth
salad what does he mean
ignore him
desperate please and prophecies nothing
more
walk with me wolf kissed we have some
time before the ceremony
where too nowhere in particular
i only want to celebrate didn't think
you were the type you have drawn a dark
conclusion about me haven't you
that is all well and good i've drawn
some about you as well are you leading a
land to slaughter see what i mean
dark
too dark
you there
get lost
sit down
i know i have been a [__] but you
are a good fighter
i respect that
let it be said that eve are the boldness
considers avor a friend
who calls you boneless
some background i killed in hibernia
used his guts to shine my spear
called me boneless because i move like a
reed in the wind
not because you're always too drunk to
plow
valhalla
that is where i am bound
i can smell the blood and taste the mead
i will sit beside the high one with my
axe in hand
a fitting end for regneson
you would think eh
me halfton
they will be there
atuba
no
i do not think we are chasing the same
victory
not anymore
what does abba want
to grow old and fat on the farm
somewhere with little ubers to chase him
out
he wants an heir it's a common dream
not for a warrior not for trend gear
like us
he was different before
but this place england
it softened him
what was he like before
like me
ferocious wild
with respect i don't think anyone is
like you if that is a compliment i
missed it
all i need to say is
things were easier some time ago if it
bothers you so much why not strike out
on your own
because he is my brother
i love him
and i will do what it takes to drag him
back around to my way of thinking
we are warriors all
and that is to the death
ah
[Music]
huh
outed myself again
did i miss the crowning
[Music]
you